cuatro meses de guerra que han cambiado
la vida de este país toda una generación
de jóvenes están ahora luchando en el
frente o involucrados en la gestión de
fondos para poder mantener a flote la
administración de ucrania todo se ha
transformado las empresas han tenido que
reinventarse la vida como la conocían ha
dejado de existir muchos negocios como
esta panaderías siguen trabajando cuatro
meses después del inicio de la invasión
rusa en ucrania pero se han tenido que
transformar ahora en sus sótanos donde
se cocina el pan sirve de refugio para
sus trabajadores también recogen a
refugiados de las zonas más afectadas y
ayudan a las defensas territoriales y es
que la guerra lo ocupa todo en este país
también la economía y la sociedad y sus
ciudadanos luchan por sobrevivir
olga nos enseña los pasadizos de su
empresa desde aquí cocinan para ayudar
al ejército y seguir dando servicio a
sus vecinos
y el dinero que ingresa es diez veces
menor que antes de la guerra
parte de ese dinero es para pagar a
nuestros trabajadores y otra parte para
ayudar a nuestro ejército
según naciones unidas han fallecido más
de 4000 civiles desde el inicio de la
guerra aunque el balance más letal es
para los ejércitos que pierden todos los
días a centenares de soldados el co
capitán del ejército ucraniano habla muy
claro estos cuatro meses de guerra han
sido duros pero no tienen otra opción si
no ganar
became la vida ha cambiado drásticamente
trabajamos 24 horas 7 días a la semana
muchas razones que decir al respecto
intentamos evitar hablar sobre lo duro
que está siendo para nosotros no sólo
desde el punto de vista de desgaste
físico también mentalmente nuestros
amigos están muriendo casi cada día
mueren por las heridas
quedan ya pocas familias sin un allegado
o amigo al que no volverán a ver por
culpa de la guerra tras varias derrotas
las tropas rusas avanzan lentamente en
el este de ucrania arrasando ciudades a
pesar de la resistencia del ejército
ucraniano